It's a magical work, but it's also--
how to describe it?
Vampire philosophy. It's fascinating.
So now we're not all monsters?
Oh, I didn't say that.
Go on, admit it.
I admit there seems to be more...
depth to...
what would you call it?
Vampire culture? Than I thought.
There are ideas in here
about physical presence in the world,
the importance of soil and landscape
and... being.
[chuckles] I mean, actual philosophy.
Amazing.
Well, good.
Then I have a philosophical question
for you.
All right.
It's hard to do diplomacy
when the other person is in a cage.
I can't disagree.
[Lenore]
Diplomacy is compromise.
I get something, you get something.
Neither of us get everything we want,
but we both leave happy.
-You have my attention.
-But you...
you don't even get to leave!
You haven't got anything!
I have all the power,
and you're a pretty man in a box.
I'm-- I'm pretty?
It just doesn't seem fair.
What's happening?
I've been awake all day
thinking about it.
You. Down here.
What's the question, Lenore?
What do you want?
I want to be let out.
I know.
That's all I can think of.
It's the only thing I can do for you.
But you're not just gonna let me out.
Well... no.
I'm loyal to my sisters.
To just fling open the door and say,
"Fly, be free, pretty human boy"?
That-- That would be a direct betrayal.
Come and sit down.
[chuckles] Also, you'd survive
less than a day on your own.
That's not true.
Well, OK, that's completely true
and I would die almost immediately.
[Lenore laughs]
You only have one advantage
in this whole negotiation.
I'm not sure it's an advantage.
I like you.
Uh, that wasn't what
I was expecting to hear.
Well, what did you think
your advantage was?
You want me to do my human magic
to give Carmilla an army of monsters.
Oh, that.
I was eavesdropping
on Morana and Striga during the day.
They can buy mercenaries
to fill out the army.
I don't understand. Carmilla's given up?
She gets distracted.
She calls it the burden of genius.
We could run out on her this morning
and she wouldn't notice for days.
I'm loyal to my sisters...
but what we're doing is wrong.
We could just leave, Hector.
If you want to be with me.